I gotta get to school.
I never should have stopped and picked all those blueberries.
Whoa.
Hunter, what's going on?
Look at that flooded creek.
I'm done for.
This is a big problem.
I give up.
Wait a minute.
Let's talk this through and make sure we understand the problem.
Maybe we can come up with a solution.
Well, the problem is that because of all the rain,...
...I can't safely cross the flooded creek and get to school.
Okay, now that we understand the problem.
Let's see if we can come up with some solutions for getting to school safely.
Let me think.
How could I solve this problem and find a way to get to school safely?
I got it.
Would you fly me over the creek, Eve?
Hunter, I'd love to, but owls can't fly very well in the rain.
I'll have to stay under this tree until it stops.
Oh well, I'm stuck.
No use trying.
Problems can be tricky,...
...but you're smart.
I know that together we can find a way across that creek.
Okay, let me think some more.
Well, that won't work.
Maybe...
What if I fall in?
My mom said never to swim in rushing water.
Yikes.
I don't know what to do, Eve.
I give up.
Hunter, don't give up.
Keep trying.
Well, there is a brand new bridge up the creek.
It's a longer walk to school than usual,...
...but the beavers built it high and sturdy,...
...so I'm sure it's safe and not flooded.
Great job, Hunter!
I think you've come up with a good and safe solution.